hello and welcome to this rapid game
played on ditches so let's go on the
London system the dodo is extinct
why does the dodo play the London system
okay so um c3
I think 26 was my choice they're trying
to provoke some concession Quincy to was
actually possible as yeah exactly as he
takes he takes 24 fields do 228 so yeah
96 I mean I force exam put some pressure
on the form D takes e5 okay I mean I
move a queen but but at least that
position is some bit non-standard so III
probably hmm huh so I have no idea what
that means
I mean 10oz I suspect that means 10
years a Veck means with the jewel that's
the day right I don't quite know I'm
sorry I hope it's not something that's
like Jack and I have to run in 10
minutes or something and I don't
understand that but okay so what is
going on here is there I mean I can just
develop yeah but do I have something
better something else most like 94 but
this probably just probably doesn't make
all that much sense
I can definitely play these things in j6
stuff like that so I'm going to use the
microphone
you
to take that phone call and yeah it was
it means that I have a bit of a time
problem with this game prom okay
I try to play quickly because otherwise
I might get on my turn have problems
here so what to do I think this is an
idea playing Bishop h3 trying to trade
dissolve the Queen was unstable on c5
anyway and Bishop h3 is something that I
feel is helpful this Bishop on g2 is at
least it's on a long diagonal the bishop
on f4 or so now okay so let's go and do
this
the bishop Ella for doesn't have all
that many squares if I get in like 94
that can be interesting like G 4 I
cannot go to e3 or that easily without
killing his own pawn structure
and someone outside is I don't know what
they're doing doing something in the
garden or rather than I don't front lawn
of the houses I think they're finished
okay so um dodo the Queen to b3 yes so
let's think about it I can do something
try something wacky and like lagi for
Queen b7 it's not such a [ __ ] is such a
big deal of it it is still something
that annoys the aid is a very very
stodgy move so it's not something you
would like to play huh so do a cake when
you do and then see how to do it hmm OPA
it looks extremely lame yeah but again
and I said yeah I'm rather what you want
to be quick here
don't like it but maybe I can let tape
on on g2 and 97 and then b5 if you like
or b5 immediately I don't know I don't
know what I need 97 but then it would be
like b5 before try to attack on c3 so
like here here and attack here
there's the bishop on g7 so that make
some sense I actually wonder if Bishop
e3 after you played it before if this is
actually making all that much sense now
well it's not a not a terrible way to
play Wow really why go for the maroc C
and well it's got the thing is his night
is absolutely misplaced and I have 94
the 94 go gets interesting now it really
does because there are 94 things going
on now let's do it come on I want to
play quickly in a bit Jim
yeah he's a little bit under pressure
they own h2 and 94 is attacking both the
Queen and the night on deform so this is
an idea the same time that diagonal is
opened up the Bishop g7 diagonal I just
noticed that b5 is also interesting like
making use of that that weird rook is
completely under it here really so 94
how do you how do you save it how do you
save yourself 94 Queen you won Knight
takes Bishop g2 King takes Knight f3
Queen f3 we should be to watch us upon
just a pawn or is there no it will just
win the pawn I think maybe I have more
Queen D 1 this is forced more or less I
mean maybe Queen d3m Queen d3 but it is
almost the same thing that doesn't make
a big difference
I just wondered
and wait wait wait with just one day
very somewhat turned to fear that
stronger even like f5 or something else
something that immediately kills him I
don't see anything at the moment I can
win a flagpole
now with Bishop g2 King takes 93 and
then take on b2 way that is not bad at
all it just feels feels like I could be
more I was thinking about night h2 word
even king cakes
seems to work it doesn't really do much
okay come on let's grab the point maybe
maybe hear something it looks like there
should be something going on and really
you still cannot take because it's such
a such a it looks a unreliable really I
don't see so takes Knight takes it
should be true I mean it's good it's a
bond I just feel like I'm completely
stupid and don't see see the better move
when it shows that I mean in some kids
the tango is high if you placed the
bishop and he has h3 really quickly okay
so let's let's
got up to the born
after he won I doesn't do it okay there
was potentially potentially the move
would be five okay let's go all the way
back the good thing is that is a dead
zone imported porn because it's the
support porn of the C pawn his remaining
pawns our wheatish now a two and C for
my best that you own this one that's it
it looks like it could be a good move
try to exploit the temporary
coordination issue our queen is a bit
bit off and there's the the diagonal
okay I have e5 but that's not something
that I wanted to play I should have
played Bishop e-file it was my first
idea and I didn't quite follow up on
that
yeah 95 doesn't look good
hen okay
I can do 95 and I know this is enough
though who's not good yeah that's not
good to that if he gets in c-five this
is this is not as great put it puts what
else I mean I ever think in 95 they are
in this position but maybe I should have
done that
and there's also the open question if I
had something like fundamentally better
air in that when I decided to snatch the
pond okay so here he probably wants to
take on you five probably I mean I'm not
sure I can with you to move like we need
to but still
yeah I love nice I think I think just 95
is certainly active enough my cleanness
is offside this is also why I can I
consider to take with the bishop like 95
Bishop e5 just to really get the Queen
yeah to get the Queen some are on the
fifth rank that it does something there
where pawn takes looks a little bit
strange anyway so he keeps my pawn
structure intact
why that's surprising
okay I know I have to take that's an
easy decision and now let's go back
color e7 and allow the Queen to come
over under on the Queen side that's
really strange I thought it will take on
e5 and damage my structure and take only
six that looked very really okay okay
I'm not I'm not sure here that might
also be okay for him but still
surprising too soon so 25 yeah cover a7
look at F to prepare work between yeah
I've got the baton minor piece that he
didn't do all I'd roll it on a good iam
that that was it wasn't all that all
that is him and this still looks this
looks like a fairly substantial
advantage unless is somehow quickly
getting the pawn back which I don't see
I don't see how we get it
I wonder what what you want is have to
be there let's wear suits free where's
the translator no translator in average
force in young I don't know what that
means anyway okay so rah rah rah rah rah
whoopee two one not so quick I'm not see
form look before looks also quite quite
good to dominate
is he going that b3 here
93 Queen before so maybe maybe cover a
server one more once more and my next
idea would be look see a look see three
attack activate more look see one maybe
yeah look see one they are very tough
too
it's tough to convert so probably that
group is having more force rubbish
galaxy one looks very very very logical
putting it on and on an open file but
that's not too good
okay
don't want to stay in the B fire 92
looks annoying so here what is going on
25 give this a set of a fairly good
dominating position over the night but I
don't have a clear plan may be attacking
before is an idea hook before and so on
give away the a pawn
maybe I mean he's not really able to do
all that much but Queen d5 me to trade
the Queens
yeah the move would be five actually
forces his queen all the way back to the
one okay so I was thinking 25 yeah I
don't know when the ending helps my hair
at okay let's do it
thank you we'll trade no hmm anything
threatens no see if I can get an H for
you probably go play H for himself but I
want to go before maybe and provoke f3
just another weakness if you place H 1
and F 3 then G 3 is weak it's maybe
nothing fantastic but so they don't know
if you want still of H for this is
always always annoying don't care come
to h3
because f4 I don't know B - probably
just yeah it's a check
rook c6 blow what is that doing
I had one understand this more okay five
or something or some weird way to trap
McQueen No
okay five I mean can I go queen bee -
oopsie - queen with one rook c8 check
yeah I mean I saw a toilet I probably
have to play a wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
what about B three rupee through the
screen B 3 oh that's lucky
that's very lucky
no then actually have Queen takes e4 so
would be three
doesn't that win then rook b3 okay five
that's easy
Queen takes Queen e4 Queen f3 h 3 well
that works huh it works
took me ages but it works I was
originally thinking okay I mean it's I
think it's the materia was gone anyway
but this is extremely easy
it's probably easiest it will trade
stuff trade Queens
okay dudu resigned so let's have a quick
look and really happy that the game
didn't last very long because I have to
be somewhere shortly so um yeah we had
this opening and I think nothing much
was was going on so I probably missed
something I'm fairly certain the the
engines already announces a couple of
inaccurate most but okay so the AIDS I
wasn't happy with this yes aphorism is a
mistake probably tactically and
strategically so 94 is kind of clear
books you wanna know very in the world
right before 23 M and then 96 is an
interesting move and at 596 is what the
engine likes at the moment and also f5
yeah I mean I hate this on the radar the
suspect is this gang whole kind of thing
if it works you blow blow the other guy
out of the water and but I mean I just
saw that the other smell thing
Winterbourne but it is dead well not
appear so whether the engines line is
really lucky
take take check and any five guinea to
only move let's completely wacky no idea
what that is
okay alright f5 some some attacking okay
are 96 okay and this this isn't all that
Greg and I think f3 this is not good am
thirty-six is better that'sa markable
and I should put it back to e5
hi it's it's it's equal this is the
thing it's just equal oh he takes acting
like Detex so hereafter h3 white is
actually better now yeah I don't have
money squares here really not you will
probably win this back yeah that's good
yeah
and this is c6 is really bad yeah that
keeps my pawn structure sound Jam and it
helps me enormous name look FC 8 was
better I mean I just it's not a bad
I'm okay with my play there maybe there
was and it was a strange move h4 and
justice was blundering wandering the
house the key line there was Queen takes
Queen before Queen f3 age throw that
that's what you have to spot and then
Luke takes me three look sir yeah this
is salia
very simple but interesting so I mean I
kind of felt that there should be
something more than what I did but I
couldn't quite bring myself to play it
but then the main thing was I saw that
I'm winning a pawn I didn't quite see
any compensation and he might definitely
have some compensation so I was thinking
I'm just a pawn up and this is okay I
wasn't really anticipating that white
would have compensation and NT
definitely handsome it was the main
thing if I would have realised that this
isn't just a clear pawn up and would
have looked harder for something more
more aggressive okay guys thanks for
watching